my king the Europeans wish to conquer us
they will not stop into the whole of
Africa is theirs
we must fight back
for our people
that is
some things are worth fighting for
I cannot begin to describe how
incredible this film is and thank you
all so much for making it it is so dope
um Gina I have to start with you I I
want people to see it it's aspirational
it's regal it's Fierce and it is the
best piece of wish fulfillment because
it actually happened and we just didn't
know so where did it start with you when
you set about to put this incredible
epic with these incredible black women
and John
I like that
um I'm going to start with two things
that started with Viola Davis was
attached and it started with the script
reading the script it literally took me
five minutes and I read that these women
rise about the grass and I said I gotta
shoot that and as I kept reading I just
kept getting more and more enamored by
these women that I had never heard of
before and not just how badass they were
but the humanity of it The Sisterhood
and just the more I read the more then I
started to research the more I wanted to
put that up on screen for us certainly
to be inspired by but the world as well
the way I came out of it I just said is
so fierce but it was incredibly feminine
like right in the middle of these huge
battle sequences you saw just black
women doing their thing man it was so
great and Miss Viola Davis to see you at
the center of that again I just I didn't
know I wanted to see you beat that many
people but I'm so glad that I did and
you know what I want to beat that man
that's what I wanted to ask you like how
much of that was fulfilling for you not
just as an actor but as a black woman
but just somebody who's been on these
sets and seen this stuff as part of your
craft and really getting to dive all the
way into it with this one well you know
I think that when I started off being an
actor I just wanted to be like Miss
Tyson I wanted to create Magic that sort
of
um you know
that Alchemy you know to put out in the
world and I wanted to be somebody and
then as I went out into the acting
profession I realized how little agency
we had as black actors and especially as
black women
and when I say agency Not only was our
presence not seen in movies when it was
seen we were metaphors we were devices
we were best friends and we were never
ever complicated or beautiful
and then that was probably the biggest
disappointment in my life so shooting
this movie it was like somebody really
um handed me my dream on a plate
you know it's like God spoke to me and
said you know what it's possible when I
didn't think that it was you know I mean
this is ours we're at the center of this
narrative our strength our Beauty our
our we matter we matter you know we do
we matter and we can and we could
spearhead a movie and put it forth in
the world and everybody wants to see it
you know everything that I've been told
as an actor and as a black woman I
didn't realize how much of it was a lie
and this is my redefinition of it my
opinion thank you speak on it I'm sorry
I'm like I need to like stay
professional like you're really pushing
me
um I'm gonna make it light on this way
and I'm like trying to like stay
composed and she just takes us to church
about the real too so I I have to say I
feel blessed to be in this room but girl
you look Barry Jenkins Underground
Railroad and doing that and then this
like I would say like was it you know I
wouldn't even say intimidated or like
amazing or thrilling because I'm like
you already went on this Odyssey and now
you get to do a Viola Davis and these
other women so what was it like coming
onto this set knowing that yes it's
going to be a huge undertaking of a role
but also the physical and then the
people you're coming along with it like
what was it like going on this journey
with this team
it was nothing short of amazing I think
and for me it started like way before
set
um after having been caused Gina and I
went on our own adventure Muay Thai
sessions one-on-one sessions
and then pre-production training where I
got to meet everyone and work with
everyone quite closely
um suffering together struggling getting
stronger crying wanting to create but
then you know here we are and then like
by the time we got to set we'd already
built such a solid relationship that um
there was no space to be intimidated or
to be scared it was the realization of a
collective dream you know it was us now
playing and putting together a project
that we would then give the world and
yeah
uh John I'm gonna bring it to you sir
and I'll just put it to you this way I
just loved watching you in this role
just embody this Regal King I was like
this is like coming to America three
right here in like a totally different
way but in like that same aspirational
sort of reality to it but this is a real
historical figure that not a lot of
people knew about it was that what
really attracted you to this the real
life aspect of this or was stepping into
I mean I think it's similarly like with
breaking you've done this before you've
stepped into these real men does that
change it when it's a movie like this of
the scale I just wanted to be on sale
so every day you know it's not every day
you get the opportunity and and Gina
also um having having directed some of
my favorite movies I wanted to witness
something special I I didn't know
whether I'd had the opportunity to be in
a movie like this
um because of the reality that we know
of this industry but hopefully that you
know we hope and we have faith that will
change but I just wanted to witness
black women just not black but brown
skin darker women uh being exalted in
this way
um in a way that I hadn't I haven't
recently seen in in in in in in its
grounding energy and as Viola said to
have the best friends or facilitator to
a white man story and I just wanted to
to see them facilitate themselves and
that for me was it was great to witness
it was powerful and and I just I cannot
tell people enough about what they're
going to get to see on screen and you
two ladies did a lot of that I would say
both physically but also just what you
do by the way we need to split Lashana
into two it's her back muscles
but Sheila and Lashana let's keep it
real I've seen both of you ladies do
your thing in physical roles recently
literally recently both of you so but I
have to say y'all really took it up a
notch with this one both of you did have
to do it so talk about that knowing yes
you've done physical roles before and
LaShawn I'll start with you but just
what you guys had to up do on the
training with this one because I've
heard about what Gina did to y'all
what's in the Press notes I mean they
told me
oh wow that's yeah I've done stunts
before I've done physical work I have a
physical background but nothing in in
life can prepare you for you know the
amount of um the debts you have to go to
in your mind to undertake a physical
role like this and also to have a
director black woman who can look at you
just by the work that you've done and
just by I don't know what else you saw
Gina because I didn't believe it myself
but you were like so you're doing your
own stunts and I was like okay so sorry
I didn't understand the sentence
because you know we have incredible
stunt women in this world who can also
support us in this movie
um but I was really excited I was really
excited to do that because when do you
ever get the opportunity to have someone
believe in you that much who is taking
care of a story about your people you
know it may never come again just like
you said John I don't know if if a movie
like this will be in this shape with
this vibration with this kind of cast
with this kind of cohesion and love in
and around it so um I I was ready to to
take that on and also give myself the
opportunity to dive into the character
like the the juices of the character
it's like the energy of her her spirit
is one ancestral but also I I know what
it's like to train all day every day and
not know what I'm doing and question
myself and have to lean on you know the
sisters we've created in the cast and
and have to really go there so that the
emotions you see on screen the physical
work is actually real and I I'm proud to
to say that the Legacy I'm trying to
build for myself and my career this was
a part of the journey and actually it's
probably a a real this is a real turning
point for me in terms of upping my game
as an
I mean that's what they need to see
though
it's like game and then there's what
y'all did and look Sheila I'll go ahead
and put it to you this way that's
physical aspect of it but when you're
reading the script and reading your
character you're the one that has to say
to this no like like you have to go
toe-to-toe with Viola Davis and I'm just
sorry I don't have that in me
I don't know if I ever could so good on
you girl but what was that like she's
the only one that can look at me
sorry I just wouldn't be able to you're
the sweetest lady I'm the nicest man but
I wouldn't tell you no for anything
so what's that like for you you know
what I think what you've said there is
is absolute Testament to Viola as an
actor because the fact that I was able
to step on set and feel like it was a
genuine collaboration that there's
there's there was none of that you know
obviously I have huge reverence and
respect and love for her both as a fan
and also now I I hope as a friend
it's a friend cool you know say
something and then you're like
especially if you keep those cookies
but
um you know of course I have that but
when we stepped on set we were both just
actors and we were working on our craft
and we were you know trying to be
generous to each other because that's so
important when you're working in scenes
when you're training when you're looking
at you know the scripts when you're
trying to dissect you know what needs to
be done in order to bring this thing to
fruition is to have the generosity and
the vulnerability
um you know with each other and I
absolutely felt like I had that with
Viola so you know it just allows the
characters to come through there's no
you know Rank and hierarchy in that way
and that's that's
it's not often that you get that I'm
going to be really honest like
particularly with people with Viola
stature it's really not often so that
was a blessing and a gift for me and it
just it meant that those moments where
we got to show
the vulnerability of the characters as
well were one of some of my favorite
movies yes and and watching it they're
absolutely that and also I will say
there are not a lot of black women that
have that little Oscar trophy on their
shelf and you've gotten to work with two
of them and they're literally the
greatest
that's some pretty great moments right
there
um Gina have to bring it to you next
because in addition to the incredible
camaraderie and sister who we see on
screen man these action sequences they
are intricate they're like dances that I
wouldn't be able to figure out with 10
years and and all of the stopping and
starting so how did you sort of set
about the technical aspects of that
because I saw what you guys did in Old
Garden I loved it and I feel like this
film is just even more of a grander
scale and the stunts are even higher
um
I mean certainly it's it starts with
actors that are willing to go there and
to put in the work I didn't have to
worry about cutting around stunt doubles
with this I got to focus on the
performance and the character and the
story that's being told in the moments
and that's what makes great action is is
that is the performance so they made my
job much easier in that also Danny
Hernandez our incredible stunt
coordinator fight coordinator
like what he helped me create was
invaluable met him on Old Guard
loved him but also loved who he is and
how he can Inspire and I knew I wanted
that for them they needed to be able to
trust him
um one to get them there and two that
they're going to look good doing it and
safely that's that's a big thing so that
was really our collaboration and my team
Polly Morgan our DP editor Terry
Shropshire it was like how are we going
to make these women look dope legit beat
men make it feel visceral and raw and
real and under a PG-13
but yeah a lot of great collaboration
and and vision of what we wanted this
couldn't just be action that was good
enough because it was women that just
had to be dope these are warriors true
Warriors and we wanted to Showcase that
oh man did y'all I will say with naniska
when you watch her throughout this film
you see every shade of what women have
to go through from being the fiercest of
Warriors to having to be really
vulnerable and I have to ask you Miss
Viola Davis when you were sort of
becoming this character who's obviously
a fictitious version of of who this
person could be as well as real life
counterparts but how did you approach
that research how did you approach sort
of embodying what is fictional story but
again these these events these people
really lived
um you know a great director actor
udahagan said that that's one thing that
she doesn't like about period films that
everybody wants to act period when human
beings don't really change time changes
but people don't
then this gives a sexual assault
Survivor
it's his game rate
I mean that's it in a nutshell
you know and she's got to go to work and
she's had to go to work for a year of
the year of the Year bearing those
memories and so um Gina had me read
Roxanne Gay's book hunger I read I I saw
a documentary like probably 12 times
really 12 times city of Joy about the
sexual assault survivors and the
Democratic Republic of Congo which is
Brutal by the way and you think about
those memories of feeling
um like everything that you are has been
ripped from you during that sexual
assault it's what happens I mean
literally women leave their bodies
um and there is no one in a movie in my
opinion the movie that I want to make I
don't want anyone to sit in a movie
theater and Escape
and just Escape watching on an action
film I want it to be a human event
because so often we haven't been
we haven't been present in human events
I want a humanizer you know I I I feel
like I'm an actor I mean
and so
um it was it was important to her story
because it is who she is
um she even says it my scars are are
your scars are your pride
um and um I think by the end of the
movie she probably gets to that
to really yeah I can't wait people to
see the ending and stay for the credits
I'll just put that one out there too for
anybody watching this one
um I also have to add that I will never
forget this moment Viola Davis like I
think I'm an actor like I don't think I
don't think I'm ever gonna clock that
one I'm like just a little bit
defining the word uh too so I want to
bring it to you because your character
is such a great avatar for anybody
watching it because we all want to think
we can be that badass we're not but like
we were with you
but but that character is sort of like
the young sort of brash recruit what I
loved was how it was colored with black
femininity with even within this
character and I think that's a balance
that both you and Gina worked on with
the character and talk about how y'all
did that oh well I think Navi is the way
she is as a means of survival you know
she had to look out for herself she's
had to affirm herself and so even when
she walks into the palace all she has is
herself and so her coming up against
aneska you know them butting heads
is because
she won desires to be feared admired and
you know and and seen
um what I usually say is now we fear is
being alone more than death which is why
she willingly goes to Joy
join the Army but
it's izogu who teaches her that izogi
that she's not alone and she doesn't
have to keep resisting to get to where
she needs to be and that's a lesson that
she has to learn but when she comes in
all she has is herself
of that so much
um I think every character here because
you're talking about Soldier stories in
a lot of ways this is the soldier
stories there's archetypes within it and
Lashana I love your character because
she just very much reminded me a little
Fastbender in 300 you know like a little
crazy but also really cute with it
I mean and trust me just as Fierce legit
but but with that that sort of idea of
of playing within her sort of like
playfulness she's such a big sister to
tuso's character and I loved how again
it's it's a different shade we have to
do it a little bit more like us and and
talk about that balance because you guys
were just your your chemistry together
and that's the best way I can put it I
just was like oh the big sister didn't
have
when you are gifted with an actor who is
giving you as much as you believe you're
giving inside it's easy work easy easy
light work and we would show up to set
and just like discuss it a little bit
and then just have some quiet time and
then play and then we've got it and then
we move on and it it's nice when it's
that simple because you realize that all
the work you've done on the character or
the research you've done the environment
the the space that you've created on
this set is enabled you to really dive
deeper into these people and to
represent the people that you we are the
agogio women and
um it's it's it's I realize that through
Maui and zogi's connection that they are
backwards healing so for myself as an
actor playing this character I'm
speaking to myself my younger self as
I'm speaking to now we I'm giving myself
the words I wasn't giving when I was
younger when I didn't see myself on
screen or I didn't have friends that
look like me necessarily and with
certain moments that our two characters
share you'd start to understand how
important mentorship is how important it
is to have that big sister that maybe
you don't have in your family but you
find elsewhere and I'm really grateful
that azogi is able to impart the wisdom
and the knowledge that she does to now
we because then now he just goes off and
runs with that in her own incredibly
powerful way which is amazing for all
generations to see that you know so um
it's really important having that
connection in the movie because you're
just reminded of so many things you
didn't get as a child that you're now
able to
cement in your adulthood